Yes, Indeed.
They call it: The Oneironaut.
The wondrous device...
... that grants one...
... eyes.
There, at the graveyard of our achievements, ...
... where now prayers are heard nevermore, ...
... will the line between the dreams blur.
And when The Red Tide comes, ...
... the waters rise.
And all will be taken...
... by The Endmost Night.
Those who walk The Lucid Lane, ...
... trying to wake themselves by raising Cain:
The Bourgeoisie Immaculate.
And upon the Crown of Creation...
... lonely stands a galvanist, ...
... trying to reanimate...
... a wilting flower's myth:
Kyrious, God from the Machine.
And the pilgrims, who finally found the way, ...
.... for in their Call Beyond The Fifth Wall will break:
The Panopticon of the Deep Sea.
Like ants, we dug deep.
Like ants, we built high.
And like ants, we'll be squashed...
By the sea and the sky.
Ahh... What have we created.
But worry not.
For it will always end how it had begun...
Behold..
The rising..
Sun.